Most of us know the story of the Shepard boy that cried wolf.
The moral is that, of building trust.
Model building is no different.
For any model to be useful, it needs to be verifiable.
In fact, we have already looked through several examples,
where we have iterated through the questioning, modeling, and
verification steps, to build robust models.
In this lesson, we will take a closer look at what it means to verify a model,
and how you, the model builder, can go about doing so.
We will go through several examples, of how to make a classification model and
validate it.
We will touch upon, how we will obtain the best performance from a model and
define, what are the measures of performance.
We will also introduce to you, the quantitative tools to
compare different models and how to choose between them.
To illustrate this, we will use location data collected by AT&T's connected cars
and try to identify these cars based on the driving patterns over time.
So, let's get started